we're on problem 240 seed mixture X is
40% rye grass and 60% bluegrass let's
see X is 40% rye grass and 60% bluegrass
fair enough seed mixture Y seed mixture
Y is 25% rye grass though is 0.25 rye
grass and 75% fescue whatever said I
should looked would look up what that is
75% fescue if a mixture of x and y
contained 30% rye grass what percent of
the weight of the mixture is X ok well
let's say that a is equal to the percent
of weight of mixture that is X what
they're asking for so how much rye grass
how much ryegrass what percentage of of
that mixture will be ryegrass that comes
from x well we have a percent or you
know we can call that you know a is
fraction a of of the mixture is from X
and then X is 40% rye grass so if we
multiply the amount that we're getting
from x times 40% times 0.4 this will
tell us the amount of rye grass from X
so our from X or the proportion of rye
grass from X and now how much rye grass
we're gonna get from Y so first of all
what's our proportion of Y if this
mixture is is a of X there's going to be
one minus a of Y right if this is point
if this is 1/4 this is going to be 3/4
right makes sense so this is how much Y
we have and Y is 25% rye grass so our
rye grass from Y will be the amount of Y
we have times how much Y is rye grass so
this is rye grass from Y and they tell
us that this is equal to a mixture the
mixture should have 30% rye grass so
let's just solve for a
we get point four times a plus C
multiply point two five minus 0.25 a
just distributed the point two five is
equal to 0.3 0.4 a minus 0.25 a 40-24
that's point one five a and then
subtract 0.25 from both sides is equal
to 0.05 so a is equal to 0.05 divided by
0.15 was the same thing as 5 over 15
which is equal to 1/3 which is equal to
33 and a third percent which is choice B
next problem problem 241 if the integer
n has exactly three positive divisors
including one and n so divisors are you
know I don't know 1 some number and n
how many positive divisors just N
squared have so one thing I don't know
if you've ever thought about this but
how can any number have an odd number of
divisors right because normally if you
take a number if you you know let's take
the number six and you shouldn't do this
on the GMAT it's a waste of time but it
you know it's divisors or 1 times 6 or 2
times 3 so every divisor tends to have a
corresponding divisor so I can have an
odd number of divisors well only if one
of the divisors corresponding divisors
is itself right if it's you know one
times N and X times X right which
implies that if you have an odd number
of divisors you're dealing with a
perfect square anyway I just wanted to
point that out but that's actually not
that relevant to that problem it's just
I think something that you know it's
it's not it is useful sometimes anyway
let's you know they just want to know
how many divisors N squared 1/2 let's
just find a number that has this
property well we know any perfect square
well a small perfect square will have
this property so let's see number 4 it
has its property its factors are 1 2 & 4
right so how many factors is 4 squared
1/2 well 4 squared is 16 as factors are
1 and 16 2 & 8 & 4 & 4 so
has five factors and that is choice B
you know you could do it mathematically
you could say all the combinations of
when I multiply you know all the factors
of this times itself and you could say
oh there's five combinations which in
this case is just way easier to think of
okay let me think of a small perfect
where this we're gonna have three
factors a perfect square just tells you
it has an odd number of factors but a
small one will have three and let me
just square it and just count its
factors that's this way to do that
problem I think unless there is I don't
know maybe there's a faster one 242 if N
is a positive integer then n times n
plus 1 times n plus 2 is okay they have
a bunch of things what happens when n to
see even when n is even even only when
it's odd odd odd odd okay so they want
us to see what happens when n is even or
odd so let's I don't know let's see what
happens when n is even let's say that n
if n is even that means it's equal to 2
times some integer K we don't know some
positive integer k so let's substitute
that in so then this breaks down to 2 K
times 2 k plus 1 times 2 k plus 2
interesting and let's see let's see this
already it looks like this is statement
a should be right because let's see we
could factor 2 out of this 1 so this
becomes 2 K times 2 k plus 1 times 2
times k plus 1 right I just factored the
2 out of there and let's multiply these
two so you get 4 k times 2 k plus 1
times k plus 1 so this one is divisible
by 4 and I just glanced and state money
they talk about divisible by 4 so I
think we're done this simplifies to this
if we can assume that n is even so if n
is even then are not then we are
definitely divisible by 4 4 is can
definitely go into the number evenly so
statement a is Right divisible by 4
when n is even statement e next problem
or the last page 243
a straight pipe one yard in length was
marked off in fourths and also in thirds
okay maybe I'll give some dimensionality
to our straight pipe so let's say the
pipe looks something like that it's a
straight pipe and it was marked off in
fourths and thirds so if I mark it off
in fourths see that's the middle that's
1/4 that's another fourth roughly and if
I mark it off in thirds it looks
something like this right
all right if the pipe was then cut into
separate pieces at each of these
markings which of the following gives
all the different lengths of the pieces
in fraction of a yard fascinating okay
so we're gonna cut it actually it here
and here and here and here and it here
and actually if we go half way then we
can just use symmetry to say okay this
piece is going to be the same as this
piece and this piece is going to be the
same as this piece and that piece is
going to be the same as that piece so we
really just have to figure out up until
the halfway point so let's think about
it so this this whole thing is one yard
so this distance right here that
distance right here is 1/4 right that
distance is 1/4
now what's we know that this whole
distance is one-third this distance is
1/4 so this distance right here is going
to be 1/3 because that's 1/3 minus 1/4
1/3 minus 1/4 common denominator 4:12
1/3 is 4 12 minus 3/12 is equal to 1
over 12 so this distance is going to be
1/12 and then what's going to be this
length all right let me do a different
color I want to make sure that you see
that 1/12 well this distance is 1/2 and
this distance is 1/3 so it's going to be
1/2 minus 1/3 is equal to common
denominator 6 equal to 3 6 - 2 6 is
equal to 1/6 so this piece is 1/4
this piece is 1/12 this piece is 1/6 and
then you could just say oh well it's
gonna happen the same thing on the other
side this is 1/6 1/12 and then this is
1/4
and so if I say let's see 1/6 1/12 and
1/4 right that is choice D 1/6 1/12 and
1/4 choice D those are the different
piece sizes we have D D problem 245 245
if 0.001 5 times 10 to the M over 0.03
times 10 to the K is equal to 5 times 10
to the seventh
then what does M minus k equal to and
that's important to read I was about to
solve for M minus K so they want to know
what M minus K M minus K so if we
immediately divide these we should be
able to come up with something
interesting right because this is the
same thing as point zero zero one five
over Oh point zero three times ten to
the M divided by 10 to the K well that's
just times 10 to the M minus K is equal
to 5 times 10 to the seventh and I don't
let's see if we can if we can let's see
if we can do anything interesting to
this decimal number let's see if we were
to let's just divide it so if we just
say point zero three sort of multiplying
by cannon doing all going into point
zero zero one five let's add some zeros
okay if we go take this decimal two to
the right we're going to take this
decimal two to the right
so then we get three goes into 1 0 times
3 goes into 15 five times so we get 0.05
so this whole thing simplifies to and
I'll write it in magenta so that
simplifies to 0.05 times 10 to the M
minus K is equal to 5 times 10 to the 7
so let's divide both sides by this point
zero five right
what is 0.05 goes into five let's add
some decimal points here so if I push
this to the right - I push this to the
right - and this is my new decimal point
so 5 goes into 5 well 5 goes into 5 one
time so it's 100 right so 5 divided by
0.05 is 100 so we get 10 to the M minus
K is equal to 100 what's 100 that's the
same thing as 10 squared times 10 to the
7th so 10 to the M minus K is equal to
10 to the 9th so M minus K must be equal
to 9 and that is choice a see you in the
next video